From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Here is a recording you weren't meant to hear. A guy from New York, a percussionist, went to perform in this opera in Italy. While he was there he met this woman, who was a graduate student, who was writing about the opera for her thesis. She took him on a tour of Rome on the back of her scooter. He met her friends. They hung out. One thing led to another. They had this week together. And when he got home to New York, he didn't want it to be over. So he made her these tapes.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下面这段录音原本不该被你听到。一位来自纽约的打击乐手，去意大利参加一场歌剧演出。他在那儿遇到了一位女研究生，她当时正在为自己的论文撰写关于这场歌剧的内容。她骑着小踏板车带他游览了罗马，他见到了她的朋友们，他们在一起玩，事情就这样自然而然地发生了。他们在一起度过了一周。当他回到纽约的家中时，他不想这段感情就此结束。于是，他为她录制了这些磁带。
It's scary. It's scary how much I'm thinking of you. But it's good. It makes me happy. Even if you're not here, I feel happy to think about you and to know that you're existing somewhere.
这很吓人。想到你这么多，这真的很吓人。但这种感觉很好。这让我感到快乐。即使你不在身边，想到你，知道你在某个地方存在着，我就觉得很幸福。
When you're really love and other people overhear you, I think it's hard not to sound a little over the top. That's what I like about these recordings. The feeling in them is so direct. And so today we're going to try something completely different on our radio show. Every story on the show is made out of tapes like this one. Every story is made from tapes that were intended for an audience of one. Someone somewhere made somebody else a tape. We listen in, all of us. I have to say, it's kind of an amazing show because of that.
当你真正坠入爱河而又被他人偷听到时，我觉得很难不显得有些夸张。这就是我喜欢这些录音的原因。其中的情感非常直接。所以今天，我们要在这个广播节目中尝试一些完全不同的东西。节目中的每个故事都由像这样的一盘盘磁带组成。每个故事都源自那些原本只打算给某一个人听的录音。某人在某处为某人录下了一盘磁带。而我们，我们所有人，都在一旁旁听。我必须得说，正因为如此，这真是一档了不起的节目。
Act One, we hear the greatest phone message in the world, the absolute greatest. Act Two, we have a special effects story. In that act, we use the power of audio technology to turn someone who stutters into someone who no longer stutters, so he can deliver a message to one man in Idaho. Act Three, a war story. In fact, the story of a soldier in the first Persian Gulf War who made tapes for his wife during battles, until he accidentally recorded this incident, this violent incident that haunted him for years. And Act Four, a love story. In that act we return to the guy who you just heard from a minute ago, a man trying to sustain a relationship that spans oceans, all with a little cassette tape.
第一幕，我们将听到世界上最棒的电话留言，绝对是最棒的。第二幕，我们有一个关于特效的故事。在那一幕中，我们将利用音频技术的力量，让一个口吃的人不再口吃，这样他就可以给爱达荷州的一个人传达信息。第三幕，一个战争故事。事实上，这是一个士兵在第一次海湾战争期间的故事，他在战斗期间为妻子录制磁带，直到他偶然录下了这一事件，这一困扰了他多年的暴力事件。第四幕，一个爱情故事。在那一幕中，我们将回到你刚才听到的那个家伙身边，一个试图通过一盘小小的磁带，维系一段跨洋恋情的男人。
And so without further ado, let us turn now to Act One. This Act One is the story of the greatest phone message of all time. Some people see it that way anyway. You may judge for yourself. A quick warning that there is one famously nasty word in this story that occurs exactly seven times. Count them yourself. But do not worry. We beep the word every single time. Producer Jonathan Goldstein tells the tale.
那么，事不宜迟，让我们转向第一幕。这一幕讲述的是史上最棒的电话留言的故事。至少有些人是这么认为的。你可以自行评判。在此预先警告，这个故事里有一个著名的肮脏词汇，出现了整整七次。你可以自己数数。但别担心，我们每次都会把它消音。制作人乔纳森·戈尔德斯坦将为你讲述这个故事。
The first thing you should know about my friend Josh is that he calls me a bitch squealer. Now bitch isn't the bad word you're going to be hearing in this story. And that's because it's referring to an actual dog, a fenced in security dog that barked at me and Josh while we were out walking one night. And while my scream may have been louder that evening, Josh's scream was definitely higher pitched, which to my mind means Josh should rightfully be called the bitch squealer, while perhaps I should be called something like bitch bellower or bitch loud crier. Just the same, quit your bitch squealing is what Josh says to me when I ask him to please change the station on the car radio or to stop crowding the armrest in the movie theater.
关于我的朋友乔什，首先你要知道的是，他管我叫“婊子尖叫者”（bitch squealer）。别误会，这里的“婊子”可不是你在这个故事里即将听到的那个坏词。那是因为它指的是一只真正的狗，一只被关在围栏里的看门狗，有一天晚上我和乔什在外面散步时它对我们狂吠。虽然那天晚上我的尖叫声可能更大，但乔什的尖叫声绝对音调更高，在我看来，这意味着乔什理应被称为“婊子尖叫者”，而我或许应该被称为“婊子咆哮者”或者“婊子大叫者”。即便如此，当我要求他换一下车上的广播电台，或者在电影院里别挤着扶手时，乔什还是会冲我说：“别再像婊子一样尖叫了。”
The other thing to know about Josh is that he thinks of himself as an idea man. And he always refers to his ideas as pure gold. So a few years ago, when I first started doing stories on the radio, I would call him up and ask him if he had any story ideas. And he always did. The thing was, most of them involved hot dog eating contests and all-nude car washes. One time Josh talked to a French-Canadian waitress who used the words diggy do as a conjunctive phrase, as in, my mother, she gave birth to me in Lac Saint-Louis, and diggy do, I'm in Montreal. Josh tried to convince me that this semantically innovative young woman was most definitely worthy of a 40 minute interview on national radio.
关于乔什，还要知道的另一件事是，他自认为是个有想法的人。他总是把自己的点子称为“纯金”。所以几年前，当我刚开始做广播故事时，我会打电话问他有没有什么故事点子。他总是有。问题是，其中大多数都涉及吃热狗比赛和全裸洗车。有一次，乔什和一个法裔加拿大女服务员聊过天，她用“diggy do”作为连词，比如，“我母亲在圣路易斯湖生下了我，diggy do，我就在蒙特利尔了。”乔什试图说服我，这位语义创新的年轻女性绝对值得在国家电台接受四十分钟的采访。
Just the other day, Josh was telling me about this really funny phone message that he heard back in his college days, and how I should definitely do a radio show about that. He swore to me that it was the defining moment in his class' campus life that year. Now how is a person supposed to believe something like that?
就在前几天，乔什还跟我提起他在大学时代听到的那个非常有趣的电话留言，说我一定要为此做一期广播节目。他向我发誓，那是他那一届同学校园生活中最具决定性的时刻。可是一个人怎么可能相信这种事呢？
I can imagine you really liking this message.
我可以想象你会非常喜欢这个留言。
Oh, I see. I see.
哦，我明白了。我明白了。
But you see, I can't imagine it being the kind of thing that was like--
但是你看，我无法想象它会是那种……
That your sedate NPR audience would appreciate?
那种你们那沉稳的NPR听众会欣赏的东西？
No, no, no. I mean it sounds like you got a kick out of it at the time. But I can't imagine it being like an atomic bomb that hit the campus or something.
不，不，不。我是说听起来你当时确实觉得很有趣。但我无法想象它会像一颗原子弹落在校园里那样震撼。
Yeah. See, this is clearly another example of the failure of your imagination. How many times have I given you ideas that you have nay said? How many times have I given you gold standard ideas--
是的。看，这显然又是一个你想象力匮乏的例子。我给你提过多少次你拒绝的建议了？我给你提供过多少次纯金标准的点子——
Josh yells at me a lot, especially when he thinks I'm not taking his ideas seriously. When we go out to eat, he yells at me loud enough to make the other patrons turn around and look at us. Sometimes though, he'll get all unexpectedly silent, and just stare out the restaurant window, and then turn to me and say something like, wouldn't life be better if there was a big old pig sitting out there by the fire hydrant? Why can't life be more like that?
乔什经常对我大吼大叫，尤其是在他觉得我没有认真对待他的点子时。当我们出去吃饭时，他吼得足够大声，让其他顾客都回头看我们。不过有时，他会突然变得异常安静，盯着餐厅窗外看，然后转头对我说一些类似这样的话：“如果窗外消防栓旁坐着一头大肥猪，生活会不会更好呢？为什么生活不能更像那样呢？”
But anyway, to get back to the phone message, the one Josh heard in college, I'm telling you about it not to demonstrate what a slightly misguided colorful character Josh is, but to chart with honesty the unfairness of my pre-emptive bitch squeals of doubt.
但不管怎样，回到那个电话留言，就是乔什大学时代听到的那个。我提起它并不是为了展示乔什是一个有点古怪且富有色彩的人物，而是为了坦诚地记录我那些先入为主的、充满怀疑的“婊子尖叫”。
I went to Columbia University in the early '90s, OK? Late '80s, early '90s. When I was there, they had this phone system-- I'll just give you a little bit of background, all right? And then I'll cut to the chase. They has this system there called the Rolm system, Rolm phone system, R-O-L-M. And you could forward messages to people. You could forward messages to everyone on campus if you wanted.
我在90年代初上的哥伦比亚大学，好吗？80年代末，90年代初。我在那里的时候，他们有这样一个电话系统——我先给你简单介绍点背景，好吗？然后我就切入正题。他们那里有一个叫Rolm系统的东西，Rolm电话系统，R-O-L-M。你可以把留言转发给别人。如果你愿意，你可以转发给校园里的每个人。
Sort of like a precursor to the internet.
有点像互联网的前身。
Yes, like a precursor to the internet. Thank you, Mr. Current Affairs Guy. So it was an amazing utility. People could forward all kinds of crazy messages. So one day, there was this guy named Fred. And his mother left him a message on his answering machine. And he forwarded it to maybe one or more of his friends. And his friends turned around and did a Brutus, and they stabbed him in the back. And they forwarded this message across campus to everyone.
是的，就像互联网的前身。谢谢你，时事先生。所以这是一个非常神奇的工具。人们可以转发各种疯狂的留言。有一天，有个叫弗雷德的家伙。他妈妈在他的答录机上留了一条信息。他把它转发给了他的一位或几位朋友。然后他的朋友们反过来对他做了个“布鲁图斯”，在背后捅了他一刀。他们把这条信息转发给了全校每一个人。
So do you want to hear the message? All right. So he prefaced it by saying--
那你想听听那条留言吗？好吧。他之前加了一句前言，他说——
You have it? You have the message?
你有录音？你有那条留言？
I do not have the message. I have the message in my head. I am telling you a story. All right?
我没有留言。留言在我脑子里。我在给你讲故事。好吗？
OK.
好的。
All right. So he prefaced it by some kind of a sad little lead in. In a little voice, he was like, I think you'd would appreciate hearing this message from my mother. And then the message played. This was the entirety of the message. And I'm going to do the voice for you as best I can. You ready?
好了。所以他在前面加了一段悲伤的小导语。他用一种小小的声音说：“我想你们会喜欢听我母亲留的这条信息。”然后信息就开始播放了。这就是信息的全部内容。我会尽我所能模仿那个声音。准备好了吗？
Yeah.
好了。
Oh, sorry. More background. Apparently he was not a hit with the ladies, Fred. This is what I was led to understand. I'm not sure if this is true or not. But he had managed to score a date to go see The Little Mermaid, of all movies. The Little Mermaid. OK? So this is the message his own mother, his blood relation, leaves for him.
哦，抱歉。再多加点背景。显然他在女生中并不受欢迎，弗雷德。我是这么理解的。我不确定这是不是真的。但他好不容易约到了一个女生去电影院看《小美人鱼》，偏偏是这部电影。《小美人鱼》。好吗？这就是他亲生母亲，他的血亲，留给他的留言。
And I quote, "You and The Little Mermaid can both go [BLEEP] yourselves. The books you wanted, they're not here. They must be in La Jolla. I'm not going to wait up all night for you. Goodbye." That's the entirety of it. All right?
我引用一下：“你和《小美人鱼》都去[消音]吧。你想要的那些书，不在这儿。肯定在拉霍亚（La Jolla）。我不会整晚在这儿等你。再见。”这就是全部内容。好吗？
Yeah. That's the message that his mother left him?
是的。这就是他妈妈留给他的留言？
That's correct. You catch that part? "You and The Little Mermaid can both go [BLEEP] yourselves." I love you, son. That's gold.
没错。你抓住那部分了吗？“你和《小美人鱼》都去[消音]吧。”我爱你，儿子。这真是金子。
And then-- no, hold on. Are you going to listen?
然后——不，等等。你在听吗？
Yes.
在听。
Then somebody took it-- some evil mix-meister genius took it and remixed it into a 12 inch dance version. "You and The Little Mermaid, La Jolla, La Jolla, [BLEEP] yourselves, [BLEEP] yourselves. They're not here, the books. Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
然后有人把它——某个邪恶的混音天才把它拿去混音成了一个12英寸的舞曲版本。“你和《小美人鱼》，拉霍亚，拉霍亚，[消音]你们自己，[消音]你们自己。它们不在这儿，那些书。再见，再见，再见，再见。”
And there are other people who remember it?
还有其他人记得这件事吗？
Are you even listening to a word I just told you? This was the The Producers of its day, OK? Everyone heard about it. Everyone knew it. Everyone had an opinion about it. Every single person who attended Columbia that year, I guarantee you they would know what I'm talking about.
你到底有没有在听我说话？这可是当年的《制片人》（The Producers），懂吗？每个人都听说过。每个人都知道。每个人对此都有看法。我保证，那一年在哥伦比亚大学上学的每一个人，都知道我在说什么。
I still didn't believe him. But just for the hell of it, I phoned the Columbia alumni magazine to see if there was anyone there who might remember anything about the Little Mermaid message. I ended up speaking to someone who not only attended Columbia in the early '90s and remembered the message, but just like Josh had, he actually quoted it to me, the whole message.
我还是不相信他。但出于好奇，我打电话给哥伦比亚大学的校友杂志，想看看有没有人记得关于《小美人鱼》留言的事。结果我和一个人聊上了，他不仅在90年代初上过哥伦比亚大学并记得这件事，而且就像乔什一样，他竟然把整段留言一字不差地背给了我听。
"You and The Little Mermaid can both go [BLEEP] yourselves. I can't find the books. They must be in La Jolla. I'm not going to wait up all night for you. Goodbye." The guy then became so excited at the thought of someone doing serious research about the message that he offered to use the Columbia database to look up every Fred that might have graduated around that time. No matter how long it took, he said, it would be worth it if I could track down some recording of the message and allow him to hear it again.
“你和《小美人鱼》都去[消音]吧。我找不到那些书。它们肯定在拉霍亚。我不会整晚在这儿等你。再见。”那家伙后来对有人如此认真地研究这个留言感到非常兴奋，他主动提出利用哥伦比亚大学的数据库，去查找大约在那一年毕业的所有叫弗雷德的人。他说，无论花多长时间，只要能找到这条留言的录音，让他能再听一次，一切都值得。
[PHONE DIALING]
[拨号声]
I called other Columbia students from that period. And every one of them reacted the same way to the message, like this guy Ben Feldman, now an entertainment lawyer.
我又给当时的其他哥伦比亚大学学生打了电话。他们每一个人的反应都和那个人一样，比如现在担任娱乐律师的本·费尔德曼。
Hello.
喂。
Is this Ben?
是本吗？
Yes.
对。
I have two words for you, little mermaid.
我有两个词送给你：小美人鱼。
This is the funniest call I've ever received. Well, you and The Little Mermaid can go to hell.
这是我接过的最搞笑的电话。好吧，你和《小美人鱼》都见鬼去吧。
A few days later, Josh called me back. He had found out Fred's last name from his older brother, who it turns out graduated the same year as Fred. Josh said that Fred's last name was Schultz. And I told Josh that this was great news. And Josh told me to shut my squeal hole, which I did.
几天后，乔什又给我打了电话。他从他哥哥那里打听到了弗雷德的姓氏，他哥哥碰巧和弗雷德同一年毕业。乔什说弗雷德姓舒尔茨。我告诉乔什这是个好消息。然后乔什叫我闭上那张尖叫的嘴，我也照做了。
So I called Fred Schultz. And it turns out that he had recorded the original message and still had a copy of it, a copy which I am now going to play for you. Remember, this is a phone message that was forwarded from one person to the next, each person re-prefacing the previous prefaces as it made its way from one voice mail message box to the next.
于是我给弗雷德·舒尔茨打了电话。原来他录下了原始留言，并且还保留着一份拷贝，我现在就为你播放这一份。请记住，这是一条在人与人之间转发的电话留言，每个人在转发时都会在前面加上自己的前言，就这样它从一个语音信箱传到了另一个语音信箱。
Recieved at 4:20 PM Friday.
星期五下午4:20收到。
Guys, I have never heard a phone mail message like this one. Listen to the first person. You are going to die.
伙计们，我从来没听过这样的电话留言。听听第一个人说的。你会笑死的。
No seriously, this is the funniest one of all of them.
不，说真的，这是所有留言里最搞笑的一个。
All right, here it is--
好了，就是这个——
These giddy introductory messages continue for two and 1/2 minutes, each one revving up the impending drama, acting as a kind of stage curtain that opens onto another curtain, and yet another one still, each one teasing you with the tantalizing proximity of the main stage about to be bathed in the spotlight.
这些令人兴奋的开场白持续了两分半钟，每一段都在推高即将到来的戏剧性，就像一幕幕开启的舞台幕布，一层套着一层，每一层都在撩拨着你的神经，暗示着主角即将登场。
OK, I've gotten like 95 phone mail messages in the last two days, but this is the funniest.
好了，我这两天收到了大概95条语音留言，但这一个最搞笑。
This is going to blow you away. This makes the other ones look like chopped liver.
这绝对会让你惊掉下巴。其他的那些在它面前简直不值一提。
And then finally the chain of deferral ends with the very first forwarded student's solemn pronouncement.
最后，这一连串的转发在第一个转发的学生那严肃的宣告声中结束。
There comes a time in life when we hear the greatest phone mail message of all time. And well, here it is. You have to hear it to believe it.
人的一生中总会遇到一次，听到史上最棒的电话留言。嗯，就是这个。你得亲耳听听才能相信。
I thought you'd get a kick out of this message from my mother.
我想你会喜欢我母亲留的这条信息的。
Hi, Fred. You and The Little Mermaid can go [BLEEP] yourselves. I told you to stay near the phone. I can't find those books. You have other books here. It must be in La Jolla. Call me back. I'm not going to stay up all night for you. Goodbye.
你好，弗雷德。你和《小美人鱼》都去[消音]吧。我告诉过你待在电话旁边。我找不到那些书。你这儿还有别的书。肯定是在拉霍亚。给我回电话。我不会整晚不睡等着你。再见。
These days, Fred Schultz lives in Venice Beach, California. He plays in a band, he skateboards, and he pretty much seems happy. When he sent me the recording of the Little Mermaid message, he also included burnt incense and a CD of his band's soundtrack for a film about cannibalism called Eat Me. Here's a clip. [MUSIC - "EAT ME"]
如今，弗雷德·舒尔茨住在加利福尼亚州的威尼斯海滩。他组了个乐队，玩滑板，看起来过得很幸福。当他把《小美人鱼》留言的录音寄给我时，还附带了熏香和他乐队为一部关于食人的电影《吃了我》（Eat Me）制作的原声带CD。这是一段片段。[音乐 - "EAT ME"]
Fred is the kind of guy who, when the subject gets on to future plans, will tell you he's thinking pretty seriously about moving onto a boat. When I ask him about the phone message from his mom, he says that from the moment he got it, he knew he was sitting on something big. The question then became, what was he going to do with it?
弗雷德属于那种当话题谈到未来计划时，会告诉你他正在认真考虑搬到船上住的人。当我问他关于他妈妈那条电话留言的事时，他说从收到留言的那一刻起，他就知道自己手里握着个大新闻。接下来的问题是，他该拿它怎么办？
I did sit down and stress and think about it for like an hour or two. I debated whether to send the message out to anyone. And then I sat down and listened to music, and just thought about it, re-listening to the message and just thinking, should I send this along or just let it die, kill it, hit erase.
我确实坐下来苦思冥想了一两个小时。我纠结着要不要把它发给别人。然后我坐下来听音乐，思考着这件事，反复听着那条留言，心想：我是该把它传下去，还是让它死掉、杀掉它、直接按删除键。
But Fred decided not to hit erase. And he explains his mother's cryptic message this way. He had called looking for an old school notebook. She said she'd search for it, but only if he'd wait by the phone while she did this special favor for him. But did he stay by the phone? No, he did not. As for The Little Mermaid, this was the one thing Josh was completely wrong about.
但弗雷德决定不按删除键。他这样解释他母亲那条隐晦的留言：他当时打电话想找一本旧学校笔记。她说她会去找，但条件是他得待在电话旁等她做这个特殊的忙。但他守在电话旁了吗？没有，他没有。至于《小美人鱼》，这是乔什完全搞错的一点。
My whole life, I have had a thing about mermaids-- and dolphins, but mermaids.
我这一生，对美人鱼一直有种情结——还有海豚，但主要是美人鱼。
When you love mermaids that much-- and dolphins-- you don't keep that to yourself.
当你那么热爱美人鱼——还有海豚时——你不会把它藏在心里的。
My outgoing message, first it had Ariel from The Little Mermaid singing "Part of Your World," singing like, "part of your world. What would I give if I could live out of these waters?" And then I jump on and say, hi, please leave a message for me and The Little Mermaid. And then you hear beep.
我的来电留言，最开始是《小美人鱼》里的爱丽儿唱着《成为你世界的一部分》，唱着：“成为你世界的一部分。如果我能离开这片水域，我愿意付出什么？”然后我接着说：你好，请给我和小美人鱼留个言。然后你会听到“哔”的一声。
Now put yourself in his mother's shoes. To hear Joan Schultz, Fred's mom, tell the story, that outgoing message was like a call to arms.
现在，设身处地想一下他母亲的处境。听听琼·舒尔茨，也就是弗雷德的妈妈讲这个故事，那条来电留言就像是战斗的号角。
I hear The Little Mermaid music. And he said, sorry I can't answer you now. Please leave a message for me and The Little Mermaid. Well, that's all I had to hear. I was so infuriated and so incensed, that without even thinking-- and I never ever say this word-- I said, Fred, you and The Little Mermaid can both go [BLEEP] yourselves. And I slammed the phone down.
我听到了《小美人鱼》的音乐。然后他说，抱歉我没法接听。请给我和小美人鱼留个言。好吧，听到这儿我就够了。我当时真是气疯了，火冒三丈，还没经过大脑思考——我从来不说那个脏话——我直接说：弗雷德，你和《小美人鱼》都去[消音]吧。然后我狠狠地挂断了电话。
So late that night, studying in his dorm room for finals, Fred finally decides to forward the message to his friend Jeff. Then Fred goes to bed. And by the next morning, he wakes up to discover, that just like one of those guys in one of those movies, his life has suddenly become forever changed.
那天深夜，弗雷德在宿舍里为期末考试复习时，终于决定把这条信息转发给他的朋友杰夫。然后弗雷德就睡了。第二天一早，他醒来时发现，就像电影里的那些家伙一样，他的人生突然间被永远改变了。
My message machine was blinking that all 10 messages that it accepts are filled. They were all filled with people-- like chains of 20-- it had already gone around to say each chain had hit 20 or 30 people.
我的留言机闪烁着，显示它能接收的全部10条信息都满了。全都是人们留的——像20条连锁信息——它们已经在每一条连锁信息中传开了，每条都传给了20或30个人。
How many people heard it over the course of the night?
那天晚上有多少人听到了？
Hundreds had already heard it in the middle of the night.
深夜时分，已经有数百人听过了。
Over the course of how many hours?
是在多少小时之内？
Like four hours.
大概四个小时吧。
What was then to follow for the Schultzes was nothing short of campus-wide celebrityhood. Women ran up to Fred and hugged him. Men envied him for his ability to inspire that much raw transparent hostility in his mother. The phone message was so popular that, like a hit TV show, it spawned spin-offs. Other messages circulated with people commenting on the original.
随后对舒尔茨一家来说，这简直就是全校范围的名人效应。女生跑过来拥抱弗雷德。男人们羡慕他能激起他母亲如此原始而透明的敌意。这条留言太受欢迎了，以至于像一部热门电视连续剧一样，它衍生出了番外篇。人们开始流传其他留言，对原始版本发表评论。
As a history major, I think we've got to put this into a class struggle perspective. His mother represents--
作为一个历史系学生，我认为我们得从阶级斗争的角度来看待这件事。他母亲代表了——
From a political science standpoint, I would say that both Fred and his mother are products of the political system.
从政治学的角度来看，我会说弗雷德和他的母亲都是政治体制的产物。
I feel that Mrs. Schultz's sexual desire for her son, Fred, is manifest.
我觉得舒尔茨夫人对自己儿子弗雷德的性渴望是显而易见的。
And Josh was even right about the dance remix version of the message.
而乔什关于该留言的舞曲混音版的说法竟然也是对的。
You and The Little Mermaid can go [BLEEP] yourselves. The Little Mermaid can go [BLEEP] yourselves, yourselves, mother, mother.
你和《小美人鱼》都去[消音]吧。小美人鱼都去[消音]吧，你们自己，你们自己，母亲，母亲。
Although no official at Columbia could confirm this next claim, virtually everyone I spoke to who graduated Fred's year remembers this as a point of fact. The popularity of the Little Mermaid yielded message threads that were too long for the new voice mail technology to handle. And so the messaging service for the whole of Columbia crashed.
虽然哥伦比亚大学没有官方人员能证实接下来的这一说法，但几乎所有我采访过的与弗雷德同一年毕业的人都将其视为事实。《小美人鱼》的流行产生了一些留言串，长到新的语音信箱技术都无法处理。于是，整个哥伦比亚大学的通讯服务崩溃了。
It goes further still. Fred's mother's message went on to become the most crowd-pleasing musical number from the year-end Varsity Show, a time-honored all-male production that goes back to Columbia alumni Rodgers and Hammerstein in the early 1900s. The choreographed routine involved a kick line of hairy-legged men in seashell brassieres and mermaid tails.
不仅如此。弗雷德母亲的信息后来还成了年终“大学秀”（Varsity Show）中最受观众欢迎的音乐节目，这是一场拥有悠久传统的全男性制作表演，可以追溯到20世纪初哥伦比亚校友罗杰斯和哈默斯坦的时代。编排的舞蹈动作包括一排穿着贝壳胸罩和美人鱼尾巴、腿毛浓密的男人的踢踏舞。
Steve Nadick, the show's lyricist, dug out the words and favored me with a few select lines.
该秀的作词人史蒂夫·纳迪克翻出了歌词，向我展示了几行精选内容。
Oh, here it is. Look at that. But I don't even know if this is the final wording, because I see some handwritten notes on the side. It starts off, "We beautiful creatures inhabit the sea. Fish-women, frolicking frivolously. Although no one said that we'd have to enjoy-a, it still could be worse. We might be in La Jolla." And we sang "in La Jolla" as Handel's "Messiah." "So it's time to decide what you might want to do. We're not going to wait up all night for you. Goodbye."
噢，在这儿。你看这个。但我甚至不知道这是不是最终版本，因为我看到旁边有一些手写笔记。开头是，“我们这些美丽的生物居住在海洋。鱼女们，轻浮地嬉戏。虽然没人说我们必须享受这一切，但情况可能更糟。我们可能在拉霍亚。”我们用韩德尔《弥赛亚》的旋律唱出了“在拉霍亚”。“所以是时候决定你想做什么了。我们不会整晚在这儿等你。再见。”
As even the most casual viewer of VH1's Behind the Music knows, fame like this doesn't come without a price. When Fred's mother came to New York for her son's graduation, she experienced the darker side of super stardom.
正如任何一个VH1《音乐内幕》（Behind the Music）节目的普通观众所知，这样的名声是有代价的。当弗雷德的母亲来到纽约参加儿子的毕业典礼时，她体验到了超级明星黑暗的一面。
On Broadway, in restaurants, in the shops there they would say things like, that's Fred's mother. That's the Little Mermaid. And I was mortified. Wherever we were, people would point and laugh and snicker.
在百老汇，在餐馆，在商店里，他们会说：“那是弗雷德的妈妈。那是小美人鱼。”我感到羞愧难当。无论我们走到哪里，人们都会指指点点、嘲笑讥讽。
So she just made it her job, at that point, to just walk up to any random group of people, and just start saying, you don't understand. I never use the F word. He provoked me. He provoked me. So she felt that that was her responsibility, to clear her name, to at least let them know she never curses.
所以从那时起，她的工作就是走到随便哪群陌生人面前，开始说：“你们不懂。我从不说F开头的脏话。是他激怒了我。是他激怒了我。”所以她觉得那是她的责任，要洗清自己的名声，至少要让他们知道她从不骂人。
Before my message came along, the funniest message they had sent around was something like other kids' mothers begging them not to forget to use their rubbers in the rainy season.
在我的信息火起来之前，他们传阅过的最有趣的留言是其他孩子的妈妈叮嘱他们雨季别忘了戴避孕套之类的。
Here's an example of what Joan Schultz is talking about, one of those feel good homesy messages. This is a message from Huey Hockman's grandparents, making sure he was taking care of his cold.
这就是琼·舒尔茨所说的例子，那种感觉温馨的家常信息。这是一条休伊·霍克曼的祖父母发给他的信息，确保他在照顾自己的感冒。
Huey, we heard you have a cold, darling. We called to see how you feel.
休伊，亲爱的，我们听说你感冒了。我们打电话来看看你感觉怎么样。
Yeah.
是的。
And to tell you we love you.
并且告诉你我们爱你。
Yeah.
是的。
That's all. We hope you're OK, darling.
就这些。我们希望你没事，亲爱的。
Yeah, me too.
是的，我也是。
Good night.
晚安。
Mine was so far and above that that they won't even go back to the old one.
我的那条留言水平远超那些，以至于他们连旧的都不会回去听了。
Do you take a certain level of pride in that?
你对此感到自豪吗？
I guess so. In a strange way, yes.
我想是的。以一种奇怪的方式，是的。
The Little Mermaid message was everything Josh said that it was. And now that I spoke with everyone about its glory, there was really only one more person left to talk to.
《小美人鱼》留言确实如乔什所说的一切。现在，我与每个人谈过它的光辉，真的只剩下最后一个人要聊了。
What do you want?
你想要什么？
I made some calls to Columbia. I spoke to some people who went to school the same time that you did. Yes, I did. And diggy do, you were right. It was all true. The message made a great impact.
我给哥伦比亚大学打了一些电话。我和一些和你同一时期上学的人聊过。是的，我聊了。Diggy do，你说得对。这一切都是真的。那条留言影响很大。
Wow, thanks John. Listen, what a bastard you are. I gave you gold. Don't you understand?
哇，谢谢约翰。听着，你真是个混蛋。我给了你金子。你还不明白吗？
But anyway, you are missing the point that what I'm saying is that I apologize, because you are right.
但不管怎样，你没明白重点，我想说的是，我道歉，因为你是对的。
I diggy don't give a rat's ass.
我一点都不在乎。
I am going to read to you a piece of the script that I've written that I'm thinking I might actually end this whole story with, because I want to get some of your feedback. OK?
我要为你读一段我写的剧本片段，我考虑过用这个来结束整个故事，因为我想听听你的反馈。好吗？
Oh, I'm ready.
噢，我准备好了。
I would say something to the effect of, "and so a recording intended for one person unintentionally became the beloved property of thousands. And in so happening, the message went from being what might have been considered a rather tragic personal artifact that spoke of dysfunction to becoming a triumph of contemporary American humor.
我会说类似这样的话：“于是，一段原本只打算给一个人听的录音，无意中成了成千上万人的挚爱珍宝。在这过程中，这段留言从一个可能被视为充满功能障碍的悲剧性个人物品，变成了一个当代美国幽默的胜利之作。”
What is that? That's public radio wussy talk. Be a man.
那是什么？那是公共广播的娘娘腔谈话。像个男人一样。
No, a part of that whole statement is that I'm actually saying to you, you were right and I was wrong.
不，那整段话的一部分其实是在对你说，你是对的，而我错了。
All right. Whatever. If you want to talk that fancy talk, you do your thing. But don't drag me into your serious voice nonsense. And you get to speak in this stentorian tone, like, and then America laughed at this inadvertent piece of comedy. I'm John Goldstein.
行吧。随便。如果你想用那种花哨的谈话，你就做你的事。但别把我拖进你那严肃嗓音的废话里。而且你可以用那种权威的语调说，比如：“随后，美国人被这段无意中产生的喜剧片段逗乐了。”我是约翰·戈尔德斯坦。
Jonathan Goldstein broadcasts his bitch squeals these days as host of the CBC's program Wire Tap, which you can hear on some public radio stations in this country and also find on the internet. His friend Josh is a regular contributor to the show.
如今，乔纳森·戈尔德斯坦作为加拿大广播公司（CBC）节目《Wire Tap》的主持人，广播着他的“婊子尖叫”，你可以在这个国家的某些公共广播电台听到，也可以在互联网上找到。他的朋友乔什是该节目的常驻嘉宾。
Act two, Special Effects Story. When this story was recorded, Kevin Murphy was a college student in Idaho. And normally, if he was moderately relaxed, he talked like this.
第二幕，特效故事。这段故事录制时，凯文·墨菲是爱达荷州的一名大学生。通常情况下，如果他适度放松，他说话是这样的。
Not too long ago, a few of my friends and I were hanging out in my dorm room, watching TV.
不久前，我和几个朋友在我的宿舍里闲逛，看着电视。
But using the editing gear that we use to edit all of the sound on our radio show, we can take out the stutters, the pauses, the repeats. We can make Kevin sound different from how he has ever talked in his life. So he sounds like this.
但是，利用我们用来编辑电台节目所有声音的剪辑设备，我们可以去除口吃、停顿和重复。我们可以让凯文听起来和他这辈子说话的方式完全不同。所以他听起来是这样的。
Not too long ago, a few of my friends and I were hanging out in my dorm room, watching TV.
不久前，我和几个朋友在我的宿舍里闲逛，看着电视。
Kevin was interested in using this powerful technology to record a message for one man at one business who has been bothering him. Here it is.
凯文想利用这种强大的技术录制一条留言，给一家一直困扰他的企业的老板听。就在这儿。
This recording is for the Pizza Pipeline in Moscow, Idaho. Not too long ago, a few of my friends and I were hanging out in my dorm room, watching TV. Same old stuff, nothing new. As college students, when hunger calls, we call for pizza. I pick up the phone behind me. I've got the coupon book out. I decide to go for the $10.99 special, drinks and crazy bread included. I dial the number.
这段录音是给爱达荷州莫斯科市的披萨管道（Pizza Pipeline）店的。不久前，我和几个朋友在我的宿舍里闲逛，看着电视。老样子，没什么新鲜的。作为大学生，当饥饿召唤时，我们就会订披萨。我拿起身后的电话。我拿出优惠券手册。我决定选择10.99美元的特价套餐，包含饮料和疯狂面包。我拨通了号码。
This is when the beast takes over. Anxiety climbs with every ring of the phone. This is what I feel whenever I have to call you up, Mr. Pizza Man. I've dealt with my stutter every second of my life. Is it too much to ask for you to deal with it for a couple of minutes? You interrupt, you cut me off, you speak as if I am this nuisance to your day. Well, today I've saved you this inconvenience. I've edited out all my stutters and pauses to make it easier for you. That is what you want, isn't it?
这就是野兽接管身体的时候。随着电话的每一次铃响，焦虑感都在攀升。每当我不得不打电话给你时，我都会感到这种焦虑，披萨先生。我这辈子每分每秒都在与我的口吃作斗争。让你应付几分钟难道就那么难吗？你打断我，挂断我，说话的态度仿佛我是你一天里的麻烦。好吧，今天我已经省去了你的不便。我编辑掉了我所有的口吃和停顿，好让你更容易听懂。这正是你想要的，不是吗？
When my anxiety has reached its peak by the third ring, I hear you bellow, hello. I attempt to respond, but nothing comes out. This is the most difficult point in a phone call for stutterers, getting past the point of being a suspected prank caller. Hello, you say again, impatiently. I still can't get a sound out. Please don't hang up on me. Please stay with me. This it finally pops out, my name is Kevin, and I stutter. I would like the $10.99 special with pepperoni.
当我的焦虑在第三声铃响时达到顶点，我听到你咆哮着说：“喂。”我试图回应，但什么声音都没出来。这是口吃者在电话里最艰难的时刻，渡过被误认为是恶作剧电话的阶段。“喂，”你不耐烦地又说了一遍。我还是发不出声音。求你别挂我电话。求你耐心听着。终于蹦出来了，我叫凯文，我有口吃。我想要那份10.99美元的加香肠特价披萨。
There's no response. I fear I've lost you. Are you there, I ask. My friends act as though paying attention to the TV. You finally respond, yeah. Thank God, I think, I got him, hook, line, and sinker. From here on out, all I have got to do is reel him in.
没有回应。我担心你已经挂了。我问：“你在吗？”我的朋友们表现得好像在专心看电视。你终于回应了，“嗯。”谢天谢地，我想，我钓到他了，从头到尾。从现在起，我要做的就是把他收上来。
But then you ask what kind of drinks we want. Oh no, I didn't even think of this. Now I've got to tell you to hold on. That has an H sound in it. I hate H's. They are always a killer. They start but do not end. They drain my lungs' air capacity. But I finally get it out and ask everyone what kind of drinks they want. All Cokes. That's easy enough.
但接着你问我们想要什么饮料。噢，不。我根本没想到这茬。现在我得让你等一下。那里面有个“H”的音。我讨厌“H”。它们总是杀手。它们能开始却不能结束。它们耗尽了我肺部的空气容量。但我终于发出了声音，问大家想要什么饮料。全都要可乐。这倒是挺容易的。
Oh, no. Oh, no. I don't have any cash. This means I am going to have to put it on my bank card. That is one heck of a lot of numbers. I break the bad news to you. And I can hear the oh crap in the silence of your voice.
噢，不。噢，不。我没带现金。这意味着我得刷银行卡。那可是一长串数字。我告诉你这个坏消息。我能从你沉默的声音里听到那种“噢，糟了”的感觉。
You carry on with this curt annoyed voice. You obviously couldn't be bothered by such a nuisance. To think I would have the nerve to call you and waste so much of your valuable time. If you knew what I go through, Mr. Pizza Man, I'm sure you wouldn't act this way.
你用那种简短烦躁的语气继续说话。你显然懒得理会这种麻烦。真想不到我竟然有胆量打电话浪费你这么多宝贵的时间。如果你知道我经历了什么，披萨先生，我相信你就不会这样了。
You know what, Ira? I don't think this is working. Turn off that editing equipment. It's not for me. Stuttering is a part of my life. Without it, I'm not myself.
你知道吗，艾拉？我觉得这行不通。关掉那个剪辑设备吧。它不适合我。口吃是我生活的一部分。没有它，我就不是我自己了。
OK. You see? One thing that makes it tricky about stuttering, Mr. Pizza Man, is when I'm afraid I'm going to stutter, it makes me stutter more. So one way I can actually stutter less is by forcing myself to stutter now and then. It relieves the tension. So if you can relax, Mr. Pizza Man, and let me stutter, I'll take less of your time. But I would appreciate a little more consideration. Sincerely, your loyal customer, Kevin Murphy.
好的。你看见了吗？关于口吃有一点很棘手，披萨先生，那就是当我害怕自己会口吃时，它反而让我更严重。所以实际上我能少口吃的一个方法就是强迫自己时不时地口吃一下。这能缓解紧张感。所以，如果你能放松点，披萨先生，让我口吃，我会少花你点时间。但我希望你能多一点体谅。真诚的，你的忠实客户，凯文·墨菲。
Kevin Murphy, from Idaho State University. He asks us to mention-- and we're glad to mention-- the National Stuttering Association. He says contacting them changed his life, led him to learn how to handle his stuttering. Their web address, www.westutter.org.
来自爱达荷州立大学的凯文·墨菲。他让我们提到——我们也乐于提到——全国口吃协会。他说联系他们改变了他的人生，让他学会了如何处理口吃。他们的网站地址是：www.westutter.org。
Coming up, people recording love and people recording war. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，人们录制爱情与战争。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program we invite writers and reporters to put together stories on various topics. Today we are trying something completely different. Every story in the show today is built out of tapes that were made for just one person, not for a national radio audience, recordings made for just one person. We have arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, War Story.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目的大多数周，我们都会邀请作家和记者撰写各种主题的故事。今天，我们尝试了一些完全不同的东西。今天节目中的每个故事都是由只为某一个人制作的磁带组成的，而不是为了国家电台的听众，是只为某个人制作的录音。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，战争故事。
During the first Persian Gulf War, back in 1991, John Brasfield was an Army scout. That meant that he and three other guys would drive out ahead of everyone else in their unit. They were in a Humvee, which is light-skinned, no real armor, one big gun on it to defend themselves, and some radio equipment. And what they would do is they would drive out, they would spot the enemy, they would call in bombs and troops and tanks on the positions that they spotted. And he took along a little cassette recorder to make tapes for his wife.
在1991年的第一次波斯湾战争期间，约翰·布拉斯菲尔德是一名陆军侦察兵。这意味着他和另外三个人会开着车跑在部队所有人的最前面。他们开的是悍马车，那是轻型外壳，没有真正的装甲，上面装有一门大炮用于自卫，还有一些无线电装备。他们要做的是开车出去，发现敌人，然后呼叫轰炸、部队和坦克来攻击他们发现的目标。他随身带了一台小卡带录音机，为妻子录制磁带。
And I had made the tapes in case I was killed, that my family might know what happened to me in those last few moments, what actually took place. Maybe if I didn't die instantly, I'd be able to say goodbye to them.
我录这些磁带是为了以防万一我战死了，我的家人能知道在最后时刻发生了什么，实际上经历了什么。如果我没能当场毙命，或许我还能和他们告别。
And so when would you record?
那么你什么时候会录音？
I would record any time I thought a significant event was going to take place. If I felt like we were getting ready to go into a battle or something had already started, I might push the record button, and go ahead and get the tape rolling.
只要我觉得会有什么重大事件发生，我就会录音。如果我觉得我们准备进入战斗或者战斗已经开始，我可能会按下录音键，让磁带开始转动。
Well let's go through some of these. Let me ask you to explain what, for example, is happening in this one.
我们来看看其中一些。让我请你解释一下，比如这个片段发生了什么。
You never want to go through this. You never want to go through this.
你永远都不会想经历这个。你永远都不想经历这个。
What is this? Where are we?
这是什么？我们在哪？
This was, basically, the first artillery attack that I had sat through. We were sitting under a pretty intense artillery barrage. And I was just, basically, telling my wife-- and I had a small son at that time-- that, basically, you never want to go through this type of fighting or conflict. It was pretty scary at the time.
这基本上是我经历的第一次炮火袭击。我们当时正坐在相当猛烈的炮火覆盖下。我基本上是在告诉我的妻子——我当时有个小儿子——你绝对不想经历这种战斗或冲突。那时候真的挺吓人的。
Now you had trained for this kind of thing. How was actually being in the real thing different from the training?
你训练过应对这类事情。实战和训练有什么不同？
Well, they say train as you fight. And I guess it's a lot louder. We had done simulations of this, where they have small TNT chargers that they explode around you while you do your training, but nothing like the real thing coming down and just kind of shaking your nerves up.
嗯，他们说像战斗一样训练。我想，实战声音大得多。我们做过那种模拟训练，训练时周围会有小型TNT炸药爆炸，但没有什么能比得上真实的炮弹落下来，把你的神经震得七荤八素。
Now you don't really say that much to your wife on most of the tapes. Usually, it's just long stretches of bombs going off. Let me play another one, and ask you to just explain who is talking in this. [GUNFIRE]
你大部分磁带里没和妻子说多少话。通常只是炮弹爆炸的长长片段。让我播放另一段，请你解释一下这是谁在说话。[枪声]
[BLEEP]
[消音]
I've got my tape recorder on.
我的录音机开着呢。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Damn, I didn't think of that.
该死，我没想到这茬。
This is one of my friends, Frank Carlson. And we had just moved on to what's called a screen line. And it's our job to report any enemy that would come through our position. And we were just having a conversation. Basically we've stopped, we're resting, having a conversation about some events that had taken place earlier that day.
这是我的一个朋友，弗兰克·卡尔森。我们刚转移到所谓的屏障线（screen line）。我们的工作是报告任何进入我们阵地的敌人。我们当时只是在聊天。基本上我们停下来休息，正在谈论那天早些时候发生的一些事情。
I'll tell you what was awesome, was when we were on the road. We stopped, and we fired that [UNINTELLIGIBLE], I almost ran over two guys. They were laying on the road.
跟你说，最牛的是我们在路上的时候。我们停下来，射击了那个[听不清]，我差点碾过两个人。他们躺在路上。
On the road?
在路上？
Yeah.
是啊。
I didn't see them.
我没看见他们。
They were like this. If I hadn't seen them, I would have run over them.
他们就像这样。如果我没看见他们，我就碾过去了。
And so in that situation is there just a lot of sitting there and chewing the fat?
在那种情况下，是不是有很多时间坐在那儿侃大山？
Basically, at that point in time, there was nothing we could do. We had put ourselves out in the open. And we felt about as secure as you could feel in that type of situation. And we were just going about business as normal, waiting for this to all pass by.
基本上，在那时候，我们什么也做不了。我们把自己暴露在空旷地带。我们感觉那种情况下能感受到的安全感也就那样了。我们只是照常行事，等待这一切过去。
And are there tanks between you and the enemy?
你们和敌人之间有坦克吗？
No. No, we were the lead element. There would have been us between the tanks and the enemy.
没有。没有，我们是先头部队。在我们和敌人之间，只有我们。
And your weapon, the weapon mounted on your vehicle, could it shoot back at them? Or was it too far away for that particular weapon?
那你们的武器，装在车上的武器，能回击他们吗？还是太远了？
No, much too far away.
不，太远了。
And so you're just sitting there without any kind of armor on you, just sitting there waiting.
所以你们就坐在那儿，没有任何装甲保护，就坐在那儿等？
Sitting out in the middle of the desert, having a conversation, just kind of waiting for the next order to either move forward or call it quits for the night.
坐在沙漠中间，聊着天，等着下一个命令，要么继续前进，要么收工休息。
That does not sound like a very pleasant job.
听起来这工作不太愉快。
It's really hard to relay your combat experiences of what you went through to a person that has not been in that situation before. When you are actually in the battle, you have this immense fear of being killed. I just felt like-- when I was sitting through those artillery attacks, I just knew at any second one of those artillery rounds was going to land in my lap and kill me. That is just what it felt like. They are exploding all around you. And you just have this immense terror that the next one that goes off, you're not even going to know it's there. And it's just going to blow you to bits. And then you would go in, and you engage these guys that were firing at you, and destroy them. And you'd be elated. They died, you didn't. You're alive. All right.
要把你经历过的战斗体验传达给一个从没经历过的人，真的很难。当你身处战场时，那种对死亡的恐惧是巨大的。我只是觉得——当坐在炮火覆盖下时，我知道任何一秒钟都有炮弹落在我膝盖上把我炸死。感觉就是这样。它们在你周围爆炸。你有一种巨大的恐惧，担心下一枚响的时候，你甚至不知道它在那儿。然后你会瞬间被炸成碎片。接着你要去和那些向你开火的家伙交战，摧毁他们。然后你会感到欣喜若狂。他们死了，你没死。你还活着。好吧。
And then you move on to the next little conflict. And then you'd be back down in the pits of fear, of you're just going to die on this. And then you get through, and you destroy them, and you're elated again. It was just an emotional roller coaster going through that.
然后你进入下一个小冲突。接着你又会回到恐惧的深渊，感觉自己就要在那场战斗中死掉。然后你挺过去，摧毁了他们，又感到狂喜。这真是情感上的过山车。
And about the only people I could really-- besides soldiers that have been in the same situation, would probably be a victim of a violent crime, that has gone through that fear of-- they just know that they're going to die, because that person standing on the other side of the gun is just going to pull the trigger. And then when they make it out of that, the elation that they feel, I am alive.
除了经历过同样情况的士兵，我真的能（感同身受）的人可能就是暴力犯罪的受害者，经历过那种死亡的恐惧——他们知道自己要死了，因为站在枪口另一端的那个人就要扣动扳机。然后当他们死里逃生时，那种狂喜，我活着。
I've come to the conclusion that if you can hear the artillery, you are still alive.
我得出一个结论：如果你能听到炮火声，那你还活着。
Is that incoming?
那是炮火逼近了吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
There?
在那里？
Exactly.
没错。
The last round you heard, where it kind of shut the tape recorder down, exploded right behind us. They were just kind of feeling around for us, where we were. And they had us pretty much. We had been sitting in the same location for a while.
刚才你听到的最后一轮，录音机录着录着就关了，它就在我们身后爆炸了。他们只是在摸索我们的位置。他们基本已经锁定我们了。我们在同一个位置坐了有一阵子了。
Come on. Do your [BLEEP] job, artillery. Take out their [BLEEP]. I don't [BLEEP] care if you [BLEEP] kill [UNINTELLIGIBLE] [BLEEP] artillery [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Just kill them. [BLEEP] kill them.
来啊。干你们的[消音]工作吧，炮兵。把他们的[消音]给干掉。我不在乎你们[消音]杀死[听不清][消音]炮兵[听不清]。干掉他们。[消音]干掉他们。
Man, they're firing up some [BLEEP].
伙计，他们正在发射一些[消音]。
What is it like for you to hear these tapes?
听这些磁带对你来说是什么感觉？
It gives me an adrenaline rush. It kind of brings me back to the battle. Sometimes it's more than I really care to think about, because it brings back a lot of aspects that the mind has kind of forgotten, and has done that for a reason.
它给了我一阵肾上腺素。它把我带回了战场。有时候，这超出了我想考虑的范围，因为它带回了大脑已经遗忘的很多方面，而遗忘是有原因的。
I know that that's one reason why you were hesitant to talk to us, that your wife was concerned about you listening back to these tapes and thinking through all this again.
我知道这也是你最初对和我们谈话犹豫的原因，你的妻子担心你听这些磁带会再次思考这一切。
For a couple years after the Gulf War, I had trouble sleeping. And I had nightmares. And she didn't want that stuff to resurface.
海湾战争后的几年里，我失眠，做噩梦。她不希望那些东西重现。
Did your wife eventually listen to these tapes that you originally made for her?
你的妻子最终听了你最初为她录的这些磁带吗？
No. She has not listened to those.
没有。她没听过。
Could you talk about the impulse that made you want to make the tapes, that you wanted her to have a tape if something would happen to you, a tape of the moment that it happened?
你能谈谈让你录制磁带的冲动吗，你希望如果自己出了什么事，她能有一盘磁带，录着那一刻发生的真实情况？
I think it's tough. As a soldier, I've dealt with friends dying and death. And I think it's the not knowing of the family members that is the bad thing about it. Even if what had taken place, even though it wasn't pleasant, that answers a lot of questions.
我觉得这很沉重。作为一名士兵，我见证过朋友的死亡。我觉得不让家属知道真相是最糟糕的事。即使发生的事不愉快，它也能回答很多问题。
[MILITARY RADIO NOISES]
[军用无线电噪音]
Now on February 27, 1991, you made some recordings. Let me just ask you to explain what's going on in this first one.
现在在1991年2月27日，你录了一些音。让我请你解释一下第一段发生了什么。
Well, what had happened is, we were on a screen line again. And our tanks and Bradleys had stopped to refuel. This is something that happened about every two to two and a half hours. We happened to be sitting-- part of us happened to be sitting across a major highway that ran between Basra and Baghdad.
嗯，发生的是我们又在屏障线上。我们的坦克和布拉德利战车停下来加油。这大约每两到两个半小时发生一次。我们碰巧坐着——我们一部分人碰巧坐在连接巴士拉和巴格达的一条主要高速公路上。
And what was happening is the Iraqi forces were retreating out of Basra to Baghdad. And we just happened to be right in the middle of it at that point in time. And these were vehicles. They were buses, trucks, what we would call light-skinned vehicles, or vehicles that we could engage and destroy very easily. So we could actually stop these vehicles on the road. And that is what we started doing. And we got to a point of about 200 plus prisoners that we are taking.
当时发生的是伊拉克军队正在从巴士拉撤退到巴格达。我们正好在那时候卡在中间。那都是车辆。那是公交车、卡车，也就是我们所说的轻型外壳车辆，或者我们可以非常容易交战并摧毁的车辆。所以我们实际上可以在路上拦截这些车。这就是我们开始做的。我们甚至抓了200多名俘虏。
Now the prisoners are just-- they're just sitting there on the ground, basically, in the middle of where this road is this? Is that the deal?
现在俘虏只是——他们只是坐在那儿，在路中间，是吗？那是怎么回事？
Exactly. We had stopped them on the road, and had taken them out, and we had-- I guess if you want to call it processed them. We had taken their weapons away from them, and done whatever we needed to do to neutralize them. And they were giving up very easily. They had no will to fight left in them. And when the task force was done-- when they had refueled and re-armed, or whatever they needed to do-- we got the call to go ahead and move out.
没错。我们在路上拦截了他们，把他们带出来，然后我们——如果可以的话称之为处理他们。我们收缴了他们的武器，做了任何需要做的事来把他们中立化。他们投降得很轻松。他们已经没有斗志了。当特遣部队完成任务后——当他们加好油、重新武装好，或者完成了任何需要做的事后——我们接到命令继续前进。
We had communicated the location of the prisoners back to the battalion command net. The problem with this is we have radios on our vehicles, but not everybody has the radio to the same frequency. So typically what would happen is the battalion commander would have a battalion command frequency, where he would have his commanders up on that frequency.
我们把俘虏的位置传回了营部指挥网。问题在于我们的车上有无线电，但并非每个人都有同一频率的无线电。所以通常的情况是，营长会有一个营指挥频率，而他的连长们都在这个频率上。
Right. So the commander knows everything that you're saying. He knows.
对。所以指挥官知道你说的一切。他知道。
That is correct. Basically, we left the prisoners, by themselves, with no weapons, sitting out in the middle of the desert, expecting that the battalion command net would put out that there were prisoners there. Now I don't know if this was ever put out or not. I can't-- but as the infantry moved up and came in the visual range of the prisoners, the infantry began opening fire.
没错。基本上，我们把俘虏留在那儿，他们没有武器，坐在沙漠中间，以为营部指挥网会传出有俘虏在那儿的消息。现在我不知道这是否传达出去了。我无法——但当步兵部队推进并进入俘虏的视野范围时，步兵开始开火。
Now what you hear on my radio is a call from one of the scouts that was left behind, saying, I hope they know what a Humvee looks like, because he was afraid of being hit by friendly fire.
现在你在我的无线电里听到的是一个留下来的侦察兵的呼叫，说：“我希望他们知道悍马长什么样。”因为他担心被友军误伤。
He saw the rounds coming down.
他看到了弹药落下来。
He did. Yes. I never saw the rounds coming down.
他看到了。是的。但我从没看见弹药落下来。
The lead company right behind us is buying up all those vehicles there. I hope they understand what a Humvee looks like.
紧跟在我们后面的连队正在摧毁所有的车辆。我希望他们明白悍马长什么样。
Vehicles continue to come down the road. And instead of processing prisoners-- the Bradleys have quite a bit of range on them-- they were engaging these vehicles and destroying them. It was not a fair fight.
车辆继续行驶在路上。而不是处理俘虏——布拉德利战车有相当远的射程——他们正在攻击这些车辆并摧毁它们。这不是一场公平的战斗。
Why, why are we shooting at these people, when they are not shooting at us?
为什么，为什么我们要射杀这些人，当他们没有向我们开火时？
I know. They want to surrender. [BLEEP] armored vehicles. And they don't have to blow them apart.
我知道。他们想要投降。[消音]装甲车辆。他们没必要把它们炸成碎片。
Now that's you?
那是你吗？
That was me speaking there. And I was agreeing with the platoon sergeant, Sergeant Mulek, about these guys want to surrender, we've got armor going up against light-skinned vehicles-- trucks, buses, whatever-- that were carrying people back and forth. I didn't feel that there was any need to be killing these people, because they didn't have any fight left in them. All we had to do was take prisoners.
那是我在说话。我同意排长穆莱克中士关于这些人想要投降的观点，我们有装甲车对付轻型外壳车辆——卡车、公交车什么的——正在来来回回载人。我觉得没必要杀这些人，因为他们已经没有斗志了。我们要做的一切就是抓俘虏。
See those guys toasting the back of that truck? When we drove by? Man. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] They killed a lot of people that didn't have to be killed, because if they would have moved the company up there, everybody would have given up. I guarantee you.
看见那些家伙在那辆卡车后面吗？当我们开过时？伙计。[听不清]他们杀了很多没必要死的人，因为如果他们把连队开过来，每个人都会投降的。我向你保证。
I was talking about the vehicles that were coming down the road. Vehicles continued to come down the road and I didn't feel that there was any need for the loss of life at that point in time.
我在说那些行驶在路上的车辆。车辆继续行驶在路上，我觉得没必要在那时候夺走生命。
Why? Why?
为什么？为什么？
Why do they shoot them?
他们为什么要射杀他们？
(SUBJECT)JOHN BRASFIELD: They don't have to kill them.
约翰·布拉斯菲尔德：他们没必要杀了他们。
I know. They don't.
我知道。他们没必要。
It's a light-skinned vehicle. Now like that one we killed, I understand that. That could kill us.
那是轻型外壳车辆。现在像我们杀的那辆，我明白。那会杀了我们。
Oh yeah they were [BLEEP] running. They had weapons.
哦，是的，他们[消音]在逃跑。他们有武器。
They had to do that. That vehicle had to be killed. But these trucks that are full of people. They don't have to kill them.
他们必须那么做。那辆车必须被干掉。但这些满载人的卡车。他们没必要杀了他们。
No.
没有。
I felt that, at that point in time, if we would have set up a roadblock, that we could have processed Iraqi prisoners all day. And there was no need for the unnecessary taking of human life.
在那时候，我觉得如果我们设个路障，我们可以整天处理伊拉克俘虏。根本没必要造成不必要的人员伤亡。
What gets me is these guys don't want to fight. You saw the equipment we blew up. They could have wasted us. They were coming down the road.
让我受不了的是这些家伙不想打仗。你看见我们炸毁的装备了。他们本来可以干掉我们的。他们正开在路上。
This is X-ray. We have got a truck with troops on it, moving down [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
这是X射线。我们有一辆载着部队的卡车，正在移动[听不清]
Don't shoot it.
别射击它。
See? He's telling them to engage.
看见没？他在叫他们进攻。
Why don't you tell them, sir, they they are willing to surrender? Tell him that. Why don't you tell the commander that? It's murder.
为什么你不告诉他们，长官，他们愿意投降？告诉他。为什么你不告诉指挥官？这是谋杀。
You're on here saying, it's murder. Tell the commander that they are willing to surrender. Did anyone tell the commanders that these guys were probably willing to surrender?
你在无线电里说，“这是谋杀。”告诉指挥官他们愿意投降。有没有人告诉指挥官这些人很可能愿意投降？
I can't recall if we did or not. I'm sure that the platoon leader did make some reference that these guys didn't have any fight left in them. But I couldn't tell you if that was actually said or not. It just felt like we were doing the wrong thing.
我不记得我们是否说了。我相信排长确实提到过这些家伙没有斗志了。但我无法告诉你是否真的说了。感觉就是我们在做错误的事。
Now since then, you have had a lot more combat experience. This is still pretty early in your combat career. Just explain briefly where else you served and where else you saw combat.
从那时起，你有过更多战斗经验。这还是你战斗生涯的早期。简单说明一下你在哪儿服役，在哪儿见过战斗。
Well, I was in the Gulf War. I finished that out. And I've also spent time in the Bosnia Kosovo conflict. With the Kosovo conflict, flying military intelligence missions for that.
嗯，我参加了海湾战争。我完成了那场战争。我还参加了波斯尼亚和科索沃冲突。在科索沃冲突中，执行军事侦察任务。
And with more combat experience, do you feel the same way, that it was wrong for the commanders to just fire on these guys and not try to get them to surrender?
有了更多战斗经验，你还觉得指挥官向他们开火而不试图让他们投降是错误的吗？
No, actually my view has changed quite a bit. It has done almost a 180. And I feel now that what we did was right, that we were not actually murdering people unnecessarily. We were soldiers, they were soldiers. There is risk. They knew what the risk is.
不，实际上我的观点已经改变了很多。几乎180度大转弯。我现在觉得我们所做的是对的，我们实际上并没有无谓地谋杀人。我们是士兵，他们是士兵。有风险。他们知道风险是什么。
People that haven't been exposed, they may listen to those tapes and still feel like it was murder. As I grew a little bit more battle hardened, I realized there are risks. And they were risks that those soldiers were willing to take. They were risks I was taking at the same time. It could have been me that was killed.
没经历过的人可能会听这些磁带，仍然觉得那是谋杀。随着我变得更久经沙场，我意识到存在风险。那些是那些士兵愿意承担的风险。那也是我当时承担的风险。死的人可能是我的。
This particular set of events on February 27, 1991 has gotten a certain amount of press coverage. Seymour Hersh wrote about it in The New Yorker. It was on ABC News. It has gotten a certain amount of coverage. Do you feel like the media's attention to it and the public's attention to it misunderstands it?
1991年2月27日这具体的事件在媒体上受到了一定的关注。西摩·赫什在《纽约客》上写过这件事。美国广播公司新闻台也报道过。受到了一定的关注。你觉得媒体的注意和公众的注意是否误解了它？
The information that was put out in ABC News and the Hersh article, I think, was kind of one-sided. They used parts of my tape in the Hersh article. And they took the tape out of context to kind of support what I felt was their point of view. And they were trying to build a case that American soldiers had killed innocent POWs illegally, and that everybody knew what was going on.
ABC新闻和赫什文章中发布的信息，我觉得有点片面。他们在赫什文章中使用了我的磁带片段。他们把磁带断章取义，来支持他们眼中的观点。他们试图建立一个案例，证明美国士兵非法杀害了无辜战俘，而且每个人都知道发生了什么。
It's more of a deal if you have another My Lai Massacre during the Gulf War than if you actually say that if prisoners were killed, it was because of lack of communication. It was almost like a friendly fire accident. If they were killed, if they indeed were killed, I imagine it was a communication problem that took place, and that the people that killed them-- they wouldn't have done it intentionally-- did not know that these were prisoners, did not know these people were not armed, and did not know they did not pose a threat.
如果海湾战争中发生了另一场“美莱村大屠杀”，比仅仅说如果战俘被杀是因为缺乏沟通，更像是个新闻。那简直就像友军误伤事故。如果他们被杀，如果他们确实被杀了，我想那是沟通问题导致的，而且杀死他们的人——他们不会是故意的——并不知道这些人是战俘，不知道这些人没武装，也不知道这些人不构成威胁。
The guys who were killing them never got word that these guys weren't armed.
杀死他们的家伙从未收到这些人没武装的消息。
That's right. It's more of a story when we have American soldiers that are renegades out there, intentionally killing enemy prisoners of war. And that's not the case. If you sit there, and you listen to the tapes, and you listen to what was going on, there was a lot of confusion on the battlefield. And there's no proof-- even the scouts, even though they felt like the prisoners could have been killed, or they saw rounds exploding around them, nobody actually saw anybody killed.
没错。当我们有美国士兵在外当逃兵，蓄意杀害敌方战俘时，这更像是个故事。而事实并非如此。如果你坐下来，听听磁带，听听当时发生了什么，战场上有很多混乱。而且没有证据——即使是侦察兵，尽管他们觉得俘虏可能被杀了，或者他们看到炮弹在他们周围爆炸，没人真正看见任何人被杀。
John, do you have friends who you served with in these particular fights who still feel like it was wrong to kill those guys?
约翰，你有和你一起参加这些战斗的朋友，仍然觉得杀掉那些人是错误的吗？
Yes, I do. And some of these people have a real difficult time-- they just never-- some of them just have this sense of guilt, where they feel like they have killed people unnecessarily, or were part of a team that killed people unnecessarily, and some of what we did was wrong.
是的，我有。这些人中有些人处境非常艰难——他们只是——有些人有一种负罪感，觉得他们无谓地杀害了人，或者是杀人团队的一员，他们做的一些事是错的。
I've struggled through that myself. And I feel what we did was right, and what we did was just, and we did what we had to do. And I've moved on with my life. I was able to do that because I came to that conclusion. If I had felt like I had murdered people on the battlefield, I don't think I could live with myself. I think I would have a lot of stress and grief, and not be able to deal with a lot of issues.
我也挣扎过。我感到我们做的是对的，我们所做的是正义的，我们做了必须做的事。我已经走出阴影，过上自己的生活了。我能做到是因为我得出了这个结论。如果我觉得我在战场上杀人，我想我无法与自己和解。我想我会承受巨大的压力和痛苦，无法处理很多问题。
I think that's basically what it comes down to. You've got to either rationalize what you did, or you're going to live with a lot of guilt.
我想这基本就是结论了。你必须要么把你所做的事合理化，要么就背负着巨大的负罪感活着。
When you take a moment and you reflect on it, do you feel like there's a part of you that's rationalizing?
当你回顾往事时，你觉得你身上有一部分在合理化吗？
I did my rationalization some time ago. And I've made my decision on what I did was right. And I stick with it. And I've rationalized at that point. I think you've got to do that so you can live with yourself.
我在一段时间前做过合理化。对于我所做的事是对的，我已经做出了决定。并且我坚持它。我那时确实合理化了。我想你必须这么做，才能过下去。
John Brasfield now has a job as a flight instructor for civilians in Wichita, Kansas. He is also in the Army Reserve.
约翰·布拉斯菲尔德现在在堪萨斯州威奇托市担任平民飞行教练。他也是陆军预备役成员。
[MUSIC - "THE BATTLE IS OVER (BUT THE WAR GOES ON)," BROWNIE MCGHEE AND SONNY TERRY]
[音乐 - "THE BATTLE IS OVER (BUT THE WAR GOES ON)," BROWNIE MCGHEE AND SONNY TERRY]
Act Four, Love Story. Well, let's return to the guy who's recording we heard at the beginning of today's program, the percussionist who met the woman in Italy and had started sending her tapes. His name is David Cossin. He sent her over a dozen tapes after their week together, trying to convince her to please, please visit him in New York City.
第四幕，爱情故事。好吧，让我们回到节目开头听到的那个录音的主人身上，那个在意大利遇到这个女人并开始给她寄磁带的打击乐手。他叫大卫·科辛。在他们在一起的那周后，他给她寄了十几盘磁带，试图说服她，求求你，一定要来纽约见他。
These tapes are such a complete portrait of a certain kind of quest and a certain feeling you get early in a relationship. And he agreed to let us play some excerpts here on the radio.
这些磁带完整地描绘了某种追求和在一段感情早期产生的特定感觉。他同意让我们在电台播出其中的一些片段。
It's David. I thought I would try to make you a little tape, give you a little tour, or a picture, of how it is in New York. And I guess I will tune in and out with the events of my day. I'm in my apartment. There are instruments everywhere here. [PLAYS INSTRUMENTS]
我是大卫。我想试着给你录一盘小磁带，给你一点纽约的导览，或者画面。我想我会随手记录我生活中的点滴。我在我的公寓里。这里到处都是乐器。[演奏乐器]
And there's a vibraphone. [PLAYS VIBRAPHONE] Hopefully one day you could see all of this. So I will turn off now, and come back later, and talk to you some more.
还有一个颤音琴。[演奏颤音琴]希望有一天你能亲眼见到所有这些。所以我现在要关掉了，稍后再回来跟你多说几句。
I'm about to leave my apartment. So you'll hear Chinatown. Usually there are people hanging out in front of my building, old Chinese ladies. So this is my neighborhood. It's nice. There is a bus here, filled with Chinese people going on a tour. And this neighborhood is pretty residential. At nighttime it's very quiet. In the daytime there are a lot of children. You can hear them from my apartment. At lunchtime they're out in the schoolyard playing.
我正要离开我的公寓。所以你会听到唐人街的声音。通常我楼下有很多人闲逛，有中国老太太。所以这就是我的社区。挺好的。这儿有辆巴士，装满了去旅游的中国人。这个社区主要是住宅区。晚上非常安静。白天有很多孩子。你在我的公寓里就能听到。午饭时间他们都在操场上玩。
And everything that I see, I think of you. So I thought I could just talk to you as I see them. You have to let me know if it is incredibly boring or if you like this. So I'm going to a rehearsal today in Queens, close to my parents' house.
我看到的一切，我都想到了你。所以我想我看到什么就可以直接和你说。如果听起来极其无聊或者你喜欢，你都得告诉我。所以我今天要去皇后区排练，离我父母家很近。
Hey. I'm in my rehearsal. And I'm sneaking, talking to you. [INSTRUMENTS TUNING UP]
嘿。我正在排练。我偷偷在跟你说话。[乐器调音声]
Oh, Allesandra. I just read your letter. Wow. I finished reading the letter, and I realized I wasn't even breathing while I was reading. I was holding my breath. And I finished. And I realized I am out of breath, like I just ran up a flight of stairs or something. I miss you so much right now. Oh, please write me more. It's very beautiful, very tender, and making me so happy. And you're great, you're great, you're great. I miss you. I love you. I really have fallen for you. Thank you so much. That was my first letter from you. And to know that-- even though it was a week ago, my feeling is stronger and stronger. So thank you again. That was so nice. I feel so happy right now. I'll speak to you soon.
噢，阿莱桑德拉。我刚读了你的信。哇。我读完信，意识到我在读的时候甚至都没呼吸。我屏住了呼吸。读完了，我意识到我气喘吁吁，就像刚跑上楼梯一样。我现在好想你。噢，请多给我写点。这非常美丽，非常温柔，让我感到好幸福。你真棒，你真棒，你真棒。我想你。我爱你。我真的坠入爱河了。太感谢你了。这是我从你那收到的第一封信。而且知道——尽管那是那一周的事，我的感觉却越来越强烈。再次感谢你。真的太好了。我现在感觉太幸福了。我稍后再和你联系。
Well, I just talked on the phone a little while ago, Allesandra. And we'll be OK. It's just a feeling. It's not my thought. But just-- I feel confident that everything will be fine, and we will see each other soon. I'm thinking about you.
嗯，我刚通完电话，阿莱桑德拉。我们会没事的。这只是一种感觉。不是我的想法。但只是——我感到自信，一切都会好起来，我们很快就会见面。我一直在想你。
I couldn't just end like that. I'm back, 10 minutes later than before. Wow, it's even hard to say goodbye to you on a tape. It's hard to say goodbye to you on the phone.
我不能就这样结束。我回来了，比刚才晚了10分钟。哇，要在磁带上跟你说再见都很难。在电话里跟你说再见也很难。
I went back outside. So maybe I'll just record the sounds of outside for a moment. [SOUNDS OF CHILDREN PLAYING] This is New York, where, hopefully, you will be soon.
我又跑出来了。所以也许我只是录一下外面的声音给听听。[孩子玩耍声] 这是纽约，希望你很快就能来。
So David Cossin, who made these tapes, now joins us to explain, first, if they worked.
那么制作了这些磁带的大卫·科辛现在加入我们，首先，来解释一下它们是否成功了。
Yeah, I mean that was three years ago. And I guess they worked, because I'm sitting in Italy right now with Allesandra.
是的，那已经是三年前的事了。我想它们奏效了，因为我现在就坐在意大利，和阿莱桑德拉在一起。
And how worried were you about how she would react to the first tape?
你当时有多担心她会对第一盘磁带有什么反应？
Yeah, I was a little worried, because it's a fine line between somebody who is intensely trying to connect with somebody with distance and being a stalker or something. I have never really went after something like that before. Allesandra is the first and only person that I ever felt a strong need to keep being connected to on that level, especially for such a quick meeting.
是的，我有点担心，因为一个人为了连接远方的人而疯狂努力和成为骚扰者之间只有一线之隔。我从未真正那样追求过什么。阿莱桑德拉是我唯一感到如此强烈需要在那一层面保持连接的人，尤其是对于如此短暂的邂逅而言。
And Allesandra is sitting right there with you, right?
阿莱桑德拉就坐在你旁边，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
Could you put her on?
你能让她接听吗？
Sure. Hold on one second.
没问题。稍等一下。
Hello.
喂。
Hi, Allesandra.
你好，阿莱桑德拉。
Hi.
你好。
So could I ask you to talk about what it was like getting the first of these tapes?
那我可以请你谈谈收到这些磁带的第一盘时是什么感觉吗？
It was tender. It was really feeling again the presence of somebody.
很温柔。那真的再次感受到了一个人的存在。
Before you got the tapes, did it seem like such a serious thing that happened between you and him?
在收到磁带之前，你和他的事看起来有那么严重吗？
I have to say, it was serious because it was intense. We met, and we had a wonderful, incredible week. Something really special happened. But then, maybe I started-- more than him, I started to be more rationalistic. I started to step again on earth. So all this was like a romance, but I was rationally thinking, oh, I'm in Rome, he's in New York. And those tapes helped to continue the romance. And I think this was when I actually consciously felt in love with him. I became aware of that. And this helped me to believe in that love. It was easy in that situation to be scared, and to try to hide from your own feelings or your own state of mind.
我得说，它是严肃的，因为它很强烈。我们相遇，度过了美妙、难以置信的一周。发生了真正特别的事情。但后来，也许我开始——比他更多地——变得理智了。我开始再次脚踏实地。所以这一切就像是一场浪漫，但我理智地想：噢，我在罗马，他在纽约。那些磁带帮助延续了这段浪漫。我想就是在那时，我真正清醒地感觉到爱上了他。我意识到了这一点。这帮助我相信那份爱。在那种情况下，害怕并试图躲避自己的情感或心理状态是很正常的。
On the tapes, he worries about being too intense or being too boring. Were there moments of the tapes that struck you that way?
在磁带里，他担心自己表现得太强烈或者太无聊。有哪一刻让你有这种感觉吗？
No, no, I was never bored. And I never felt this was too much or too intense. It was tender. I was always sorry when the tape finished. I always wanted more. And I rewinded some parts. And I listened to some of these many times.
没有，没有，我从来没觉得无聊。我也从没觉得那太过分或太强烈。它是温柔的。磁带结束时我总是感到遗憾。我总是想要更多。我回放了一些片段。我听了很多遍。
He's so in love with you on these tapes.
他在磁带里是那么爱你。
I guess he was. And that's why it was so convincing, in a sense. I felt it was true, and it was irresistible. How can I say? I could not resist. It was natural. Really, you have the sensation your destiny was changed. I guess every love story starts in the same way, in a sense.
我想他是的。这就是为什么它在某种意义上那么有说服力。我感到那是真实的，且令人无法抗拒。怎么说呢？我无法抗拒。那是自然的。真的，你有种宿命被改变的感觉。我想每一个爱情故事在某种意义上都以同样的方式开始。
Allesandra and David are now married. In the years since we first broadcast this story, they have had a daughter, named Nina, who just turned four.
阿莱桑德拉和大卫现在结婚了。在我们最初播出这个故事后的几年里，他们有了个女儿，叫妮娜，刚刚四岁。
[MUSIC - "SEND ME SOME LOVIN," OTIS REDDING]
[音乐 - "SEND ME SOME LOVIN," OTIS REDDING]
Well today's show is produced by Jonathan Goldstein and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help for today's show by Brian Reed.
今天的节目由乔纳森·戈尔德斯坦和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温蒂·多尔和斯塔莉·凯恩参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。布莱恩·里德对今天的节目提供了制作帮助。
Special thanks today to Jonathan List, Nick Garcia and Sunny Neater.
今天特别感谢乔纳森·利斯特、尼克·加西亚和桑尼·尼特。
Music help today from Adam "the tape guy" Jacobs and from Edward Lifson. Our web site, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to all of our shows for absolutely free, sign up for our free podcast, or check out all the merch in our online store. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
音乐协助来自亚当“磁带人”雅各布斯和爱德华·利夫森。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费收听我们所有的节目，注册我们的免费播客，或在我们的在线商店查看所有周边。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助信息]
WBEZ management oversight by our boss, Torey Malatia, who keeps showing up at my house dressed as a pizza, saying-- [MUSIC - "EAT ME"]
WBEZ管理监督来自我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚，他总是打扮成披萨的样子出现在我家门口，说着—— [音乐 - "EAT ME"]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。